to Jill if there's ever a problem just
walk out on the balcony here or walk out
put that double barrel shotgun and fire
two blasts outside the house I promise
you who's ever coming in is not gonna
you don't need an AR-15 it's harder to
aim it's harder to use
buy shotgun I mean in all seriousness
for a new shooter to be able to
proficiently handle a shotgun is
difficult AR-15s there's a reason that
they are popular and it's not because
they should be used only by Navy Seals
as a scary Black Rifle it's because it's
very easy for people who are
inexperienced Shooters to handle it's
the perfect for a lot of scenarios
um former Vice President Biden advocated
a crime literally on camera as advice it
could be multiple crimes too depending
on where you live not just firing the
gun but firing in a residential area
yeah in the air right it has to come
down yes it's not the Middle East no